hello i'm haslinda ahmed
he's the central bank governor of what's
considered to be one of the smartest and
most progressive financial hubs
in the world singapore's ravi manon is
batting big on fintech
exploring digital currencies looking to
take the lead on what the future of
banking will look like
at a time of global uncertainty this
is a conversation with the managing
director of the monetary authority of
singapore
ravi manon thank you so much for your
time today thank you it's linda
when it comes to singapore's innovation
efforts one of the key areas is fintech
and the military authority of singapore
plays a huge role in that in fact some
of the initiatives
include regulatory sandboxes in which
fintech companies selected fintech
companies can test out their ideas
alongside regulators
since the initiatives were launched in
2015.
what's been achieved what do you view as
the key successes so far
oh well um we've come quite a long way
since 2015.
uh it's quite heartwarming uh how things
have taken shape
most important is that we now have a
vibrant
fintech ecosystem if you look at
financial institutions now fintech is
not only about
non-financial players applying
technology to financial services i think
a big part of fintech
is the application of technology within
financial institutions to create better
products
and if you look at our financial
institutions today uh we've got more
than 40 innovation labs
uh 2015 i think there are hardly any
many of the global banks insurance
companies and asset managers have set up
regional or even global innovation
centers here and they're doing very
interesting experiments
using a range of technologies from
blockchain to artificial intelligence
to cloud computing and so on uh in a
variety of use cases
so that's that's that's very interesting
and exciting and a lot of
collaboration is coming out of that and
if you look at the fintech community
itself
uh 2015 we had about 50 fintech startups
today we have more than 600 fintech
startups this is just over the space of
four years and it's still growing
um attracting a lot of interest um
if you look at financing um 2015 we had
about 400 million dollars worth of
investments going into
fintech that's grown two and a half
times we've just crossed a billion
dollars
in funding for singapore headquartered
fintech firms
uh over the first three quarters so
we're not done yet we've got another
quarter to go so we're going to be well
in excess of
a billion singapore dollars of
investments going into fintech firms
in terms of funding the mes has
allocated about 220 million dollars over
the next five years
to develop fintech in singapore what's a
funding plan for after those five years
yeah so that's something we're reviewing
right now
uh so this was announced in 2015
and uh the funding period is going to
end soon i think it has been money that
is extremely well spent
both in terms of supporting fintech
infrastructure and architecture
which is has public goods nature for
which this funding is required
we can't lay all the cost burden on the
financial institutions
so this has been good second the
innovation labs has booked about
um going forward um
i suppose we will have to take deep
dives in certain areas of technology
uh two areas that come to mind cyber
security and artificial intelligence
these are in a sense pervasive
horizontal types of technologies with
very multiple
applications we have the ida grant where
we support ai
experiments directly and an interesting
feature of the grant is that
even as you employ artificial
intelligence
it requires to qualify for the grant it
requires the financial institution to
make sure you train
the people so that they can take on the
new job so this is not about machines
replacing people
but machines enhancing the jobs that
people can do i think there is more
scope to expanding
our horizons beyond that cyber is
another area we've given small grants to
small financial institutions to upgrade
their cyber security capabilities but we
can
now think uh blue skies about what is
the next quantum leap we want to make in
building
cyber resilience for the financial
sector so very tentative ideas
we've not completed the review we'll
probably announce it some time next year
earlier you touched on digital banking
and
you're encouraging digital banks to
further the competition within the
financial sector space
how much traction has there been
well the referring to the digital bank
licenses
we've uh just put out the uh
requirements
uh and we announced getting lots of
interest
so i think next year you'll see who will
be successful we've got five licenses
two full bank and three wholesale bank
licenses up
there um
i'll we want this will inject more
competition and i think that's good it's
part of the purpose
um we're not but we're not starting from
a position
of uh weakness uh the banks here both
the local and the foreign banks have
very strong digital offerings
um and i think some of them local banks
have won
accolades for for for being among the
world's best
uh with respect to digital
infrastructure and offerings
it's changed the banking landscape
though right it's already changed the
last four or five years
uh the last three years i think it has
changed tremendously uh
the the it's it's been a big leap so
it's not as if we are lacking something
and no banker you speak to in singapore
will say competition is lacking either
it's
very keen competition um but we thought
we could do even more
uh so it's not a it's that the main
purpose is not so much
that the existing landscape is lacking
but can it be made better given all
these developments do you envisage
a time when there needs to be
consolidation within the banking
industry because
if you recall what lee kuan yew said the
founding father of singapore he said
that
even three banks are too many for the
lion city
now what are your views now as you sit
here talking about
uh digital banks not clear to me that
uh we are aiming necessarily for
consolidation if some consolidation
happens
[Music]
may not be an entirely bad thing but one
needs to be also mindful of a
concentration risk
three banks is not too many
because uh if they were three local
banks i mean
firstly we have to understand there are
150 banks operating in singapore
about 20 of them probably are very
active in the retail business
and a very large presence some of the
foreign banks like citibank and standard
charter bank
have almost as much headcount as the
local banks
and in many areas of business they're
also dominant in the wholesale site
deutsche and so on
ubs and credit suisse are the dominant
players in private banking so if you
look at business lines
of various business lines foreign bank
presence
and strength is very strong so we've
quite a diverse landscape it's not clear
to me that
we're going to be able we need to see a
lot more consolidation what we're more
likely to see
and what we like to see are interesting
joint ventures and combinations
between traditional financial services
and non non-financial players
that really harnesses and synergizes
rather than consolidation on its own
which is mostly about cutting cost
which i'm not sure is the paramount need
for now
ravi i want to touch on digital
currencies not too long ago
several bankers would stay clear of
digital currencies but the landscape has
changed i mean we have the likes of
sweden the bahamas
china talking about potentially having
their own digital currency in
circulation what's your view
on whether central banks should be
involved in digital currencies
we should be involved meaning we need to
keep abreast of the technology
uh we need to get our hands dirty in
actually uh working with uh
cryptocurrencies
and and and we've gained valuable
experience from project ubin jasper
because we issue the singapore dollar as
a digital currency in the
in the blockchain so i think it's
important for us to
be immersed in it and not stay away from
it then the question becomes
a bit more uh the answers become more
nuanced
for what purpose what is the digital
currency supposed to do
so we make a normal distinction between
a wholesale digital currency and a
retail digital currency the wholesale
digital currency
is what you see in blockchains um
where as with any digital token it does
not necessarily have a life of its own
but it's used to effect the transaction
and so
singapore would issue a digital currency
canada would issue additional currency
to effect
cross-border payments but it doesn't get
outside of the
banking system uh what people hold on to
are still traditional fiat currencies
so if the problem you're trying to solve
is cross-border payments
you don't need a retail digital currency
a wholesale digital currency would work
just as well
so our leaning is that
for now we don't see a compelling need
for retail digital currencies which
means central banks issue digital
currencies
directly to the public that's not how
money is
issued in in real life for all these
years
it has always been through the banking
system and there's good reason for doing
that
because the banks then create
out of the monetary base create money uh
through their lending activities through
credit
through the credit creation process if
central banks were to
be directly issuing digital currencies
to the general public
what do the central banks do with this
money
central banks are not well not geared up
to be
the people who extend credit that's the
job of banks
so we need to think that through how
that will work in practice
and then you have to also ask why uh why
is there a demand for central banks to
issue digital currencies
quite apart from the cross-border
settings for retail
and i think if there is
and this is probably less of a monetary
policy question than a political one
if people feel they need to have a
digital equivalent of
cash with all the properties of cash the
two most important being
anonymity and
finality what do i mean anonymity means
today if i make an interbank transfer to
your account
it's confidential but if the authorities
suspect some wrongdoing
they can actually lift and look into the
transaction and this is how we
detect money laundering tax evasion and
so on because as a digital trail
there's a transaction record so
when we go into digital payments uh you
lose that and not
absolute anonymity of cash because if i
gave you a suitcase of cash
there's just no way that can be traced
that takes us to libra we've had
visa mastercard pulling out we've had
the g7
signing a note of caution where'd you
stand on that because facebook says
that regulators are
delaying regulation and that is
tantamount to putting a lid
on innovation we welcome the innovation
i think uh
facebook's proposal has generated
tremendous amount of
new thinking which i think is essential
for the future
uh and all that you said earlier on
about the interest that central banks
are showing in digital currencies
have been given a big boost by what
facebook has has done
uh on the face of it pardon the pun
uh facebook's proposition is that it
wants to make cross-border payments
cheaper faster and better and it wants
to
enhance financial inclusion because it's
far easier to have a facebook account
than to have a bank account
and facebook can play that role now
again on the face of it i think those
are loaf tea
uh ambitions and i think they deserve an
answer
that the central banking community and
the banking community
needs to work on it's partly because
we've not done too good a job at this
that you have proposals like this
emerging not that the proposal is bad
but what i'm saying is that
it is pointing to a real gap and and i
have empathy for that
mob connie came up with a pretty
controversial proposal he talked about
a virtual reserve currency presumably on
the basis of the dominance of the us
dollar
what's your take on this idea yeah so
that's yet another
uh nuance to the whole issue of
central bank issue digital currencies uh
is it for purely for payments is it for
anonymity
here i think the argument is about the
dominance of the us dollar
and whether that is
a healthy thing for global financial
stability
because even when two countries trade or
when two people make transactions
there is a dollar leg it gets converted
our exchange rates bilateral exchange
rates
are all referenced to the us dollar and
then back
uh to the cross rates so um is that a
good or bad thing well that system has
served us
pretty well so far uh going forward i
think it's not unreasonable as as mark
seems to be alluding not unreasonable to
ask if that is the best way forward
whether we should find a more stable
system of global reserve currencies
again it's all about con it's got
nothing to the united states but say
it's all about the way regulators and
central banks think concentration risk
do we have a concentration risk in the
us dollar and
what if something went wrong so do we
want something that is a bit more
diversified
i think those are the questions libra
poses that because of its proposal to
pack to a basket of currencies
and i think mark's proposal uh for a
libre-like solution from the central
banking community is trying to get the
same thing
you alluded to all the challenges facing
several bankers today
in your view what is the biggest
challenge given all the uncertainties
technology is one
also geopolitics and coming from the
markets where
central bankers seem to be the go-to to
solve
the problems of the world yes so
i think
that is one of the big burdens that has
been placed on central bankers across
the world that because
of what they did fabulously during the
global financial crisis
and subsequently in holding up uh
the global economy and global financial
system there's now tremendous
unrealistic expectations placed on
central banks that
every rough patch that we run into uh
monetary policy is going to get us out
of it
i think that is wrong and i think it's
also wrong for central banks to feed
that
expectation monetary policy provides the
basis for sustained non-inflationary
economic growth
it provides stability predictability
over the medium term that the value of
money
will be will be stable and that is the
basis for then carrying on economic
activities
but it can't be that every slowdown
every uh risk or threat on the horizon
has to be addressed by a loosening of
monetary policy
um i think fiscal policy has a strong
role to play
and that has not been sufficiently
addressed
partly because too much of the weight
has been placed in monetary policy so i
think we need a better balance between
the two
otherwise it is exceedingly unfair on
the central banking community
speaking of the global economy let's
talk about possibly a looming global
recession singapore escape a technical
recession
and uh the mes eased
monetary policy but not to the extent
that some people expected i mean what's
driving some of the optimism that you
see
perhaps in 2020 well i think uh
you always want to keep some powder dry
and not deplete all your policy buffers
uh singapore is fortunate we've got both
monetary and fiscal policy buffers
quite quite good uh we our public
finances are strong
and we can if we want uh uh if it's felt
necessary
apply more fiscal stimulus likewise
we've been on an appreciating path
of the exchange rate for some time now
so that's sufficient buffer there
we have reduced the slope so the rate of
appreciation is lower
let's see how the data comes out over
the next two quarters
a key assessment to be made is whether
this is bottoming out and whether we're
going to see a modest recovery
next year if that's the case then i
think we're in
pretty good shape but if things were to
take a turn for the worse
then i think you need some buffer you
need some ammunition and so we're
keeping some powder dry
and we've said as much that if necessary
we prepared to use it
and there's still space
speaking of space i mean what policy
tools have not been used because when
you take a look at central banks
and what they're saying right now
they're willing to cut rates they're
willing to go to zero they're going
willing to go to negative they're
talking about qe for singapore
how might qe look like if
you need a qe of some form
singapore wouldn't need qe because our
monetary policy is based on the exchange
rate
managing the exchange rate so we're not
subject to the
zero lower bound of interest rates and
even there they think of negative
interest rates and qe as supplements
with an exchange rate centered monetary
policy those considerations don't apply
um we can if necessary
bring the exchange rate path to to to
zero as we've done before
uh we've never before uh uh had a policy
of deliberately depreciating the
currency
um but we can't re-center the exchange
rate downwards which we've done before
too
if we think the current rate of the
exchange rate is too tight uh we can
always
re-center the band downwards and
with that flexibility there is actually
no constraint
so we have fair amount of policy space
on on the monetary front
without having to think about qe ravi
back in may
the u.s treasury put singapore for the
first time
in the watch list for monetary practices
currency practices and by rule
in its upcoming report it will include
singapore what's your take
on whether there's been a
misunderstanding of how
singapore carries out its currency
practices
yes we've been in very close touch with
the u.s treasury on this uh very
good conversations very good exchange of
views we're keeping very close touch
they understand how a monetary policy
works and i think in the report
uh i think there is an acknowledgement
that
in a small open economy the exchange
rate matters more than interest rate and
therefore we've chosen to
target the exchange rate and that means
sometimes you have to you have to
intervene in both directions
um to keep the exchange rate on it's on
on the
prescribed path so i think they
understand that um
but they have a framework which they
need to apply globally
uh they want to make sure that currency
intervention is not carried out with the
purpose of gaining unfair
export competitiveness advantage for
kernel corn purposes we've we've
explained to them extensively that it's
never the way
that's never the way we operate our
exchange rate is solely guided by
inflation and growth considerations the
typical monetary policy considerations
not the current account on the trade
account we've also announced that we
will be transparent
in our exchange rate interventions we
will beginning next year next july
uh announce how much we have intervened
but we can't do it in real time for
obvious reasons
obvious tactical reasons uh but we are
not we don't have a problem uh
disclosing how much we intervened in the
preceding six months
so that people know how much we've
intervened is that concern given the
uncertainty
or the unpredictability of the trauma
administration is that concern that
could be used
in the event of a trade war for instance
uh
well we actually run a trade deficit
with the united states
so there ought not to be a complaint on
that front
so i don't see this becoming an issue
and like i said we've
although we've been named in the report
uh we've had
very good conversations with the u.s
treasury ongoing dialogues
exchange of views very constructive and
fruitful we know where they're coming
from we understand what their concerns
are
they understand where we're operating
from so i think
i'm pretty hopeful that uh that you know
being named in the report is one thing
but whether it leads to
to adverse consequences is quite another
which i don't think is likely
just one final question if you could
oblige me what keeps you up at night
when you ask this question to to bankers
um you get a very similar answer
i think it's about technology risk
because all the stuff we've talked about
economic slowdown trade wars they're not
entirely new you can figure out
what the likely consequences are what
the likely counter measures might be
and so on traditional financial
stability issues i think we've got a
reasonably good handle on it
since the last crisis i think the
financial stability board has done a
very good job
i think we have not paid enough
attention to technology related risks
and the pervasive use of technology has
been hugely beneficial
but i'm not sure all the players
involved this means both financial
institutions
consumers central banks regulators and
governments
whether all of us have a really good
handle on
the various kinds of cyber risks um
that or more broadly technology-related
risks
that can potentially have systemic
consequences
and can bring down institutions
potentially or bring down
or create gridlock in the financial
system ravi menon thank you so much for
your insight today been a pleasure sir
thank you thank you linda thank you